[MUSIC]
If you look at ethics, for one, most
people's sense of value and
what's important to them, and how to act
comes from their religious tradition,
or from some philosophical perspective
that they may have gained
through humanistically not necessarily
religiously, but from their family or
their community.
So, it's, it's natural,
it seems to me, to have that as part of
what you're doing in your work life.
Because that's how you ultimately operate
when the chips are down,
when you're being asked to be honest, when
you see things going on that are wrong.
Your religion really is there behind you I
think, or your spirituality.
But in other ways, too, just to, to find
times in the day when you can relax,
when you can pull back from all the stress
of work.
Spirituality, especially through
meditation prayer,
other modalities like that, is a way for
you to, again,
find what's really important, find your
essence in the midst of a very busy day.
[MUSIC]
If you're constantly busy, if you're
constantly going, going, going,
you really do, first of all, start making
mistakes.
You don't have perspective.
You don't have the vision that you often
need strategically to think about your
work, and about the firm as a whole and
where it fits in, in industry and society.
And you get tired out.
I think it's a back and forth.
It's, as the Taoist tradition would say, a
yin and yang.
You want to go back from moments of quiet
and
stillness to times of being very busy and
very productive.
And you would do better in terms of
integrating yourself as a whole being.
But also you'd be doing better in your
workplace.
[MUSIC]
My parents used to tell me, there's two
things you should never talk about in
public, especially over dinner with
friends, and that's religion and politics.
So I think that's right.
People are worried about where religion
may lead.
It's very deep.
It's very powerful.
It can be very divisive.
There's terrible things that are done in
the name of religion and currently being
done in the name of religion, so there's
lots of reasons to be leery of it.
In the book that I wrote with Lauren Ash,
at Harvard Business School, we look at
three kinds of religion.
What we call espoused religion, catalytic
religion, and foundational religion.
And by espoused religion we do mean the
dogmas and the doctrines, and
the teachings of a particular tradition.
And often those traditions, like with
Christianity, or with Islam,
are proselytizing and converting
traditions, and
we think it's not appropriate to bring
that to the workplace.
But catalytic religion, by which we mean
these methodologies, meditation and
prayer are things that can be personally
sustaining, and
which you can do, honestly, in private.
You know, you can close your own door or
go out, outside by yourself.
You don't have to be seen doing that if
that doesn't feel cool.
And then there's foundational religion.
And by that we mean the great stories,
sagas rules that we all
kind of agree with, like the Golden Rule
or the Ten Commandments.
Those you can usually bring into the
workplace and
even note that they come from sources like
the Hebrew Bible or
something, and not have that be
problematic for people.
[MUSIC]
If you're gonna do business globally, it
really does behoove you to know what
the religious tradition is, that's primary
within that tradition or, or several
traditions, several religious traditions
maybe that are within that country.
So if you're doing business in Egypt, it
does behoove you to know something about
Islam, if you're doing business in India,
something about Hinduism, and so on.
Because so much of the business climate,
in terms of its etiquette, it's the ethos,
the cultural ethos of, of a business,
does depend on the underlying religion
which is often hidden from view.
But if you know something about it it'll,
it'll help you a lot.
[MUSIC]
One example of how somebody does bring
their, their religion and their,
their morality through their religion to
work is Noah's Bagels,
the CEO of that firm, who also started
Bread and
Circus that became part of Whole Foods,
the natural foods store.
He insisted, because of his Jewish
commitments,
that the store close one day a week on the
Sabbath and be completely closed.
Even though that would affect the business
and their capability to have
another day of selling bagels and more
employment for the employees, et cetera.
And he also brought other kinds of ways of
thinking to the work where,
where he's referred to as a business
mensch, as a, you know, an honest really
caring, nurturing employer and that comes
out of his Jewish understanding.
You look at somebody like Phil Jackson,
the coach of the Lakers,
the LA Lakers, and the Chicago Bulls
basketball teams and
he brought his Zen Buddhist understanding
to his coaching.
And has written a couple of books about
that, being very explicit about how
Buddhism affected the way he coached, how
he brought his team together as a,
as a unit, meditational techniques that he
used for and, and
visualization techniques for his team.
So you know there's another example of, of
somebody doing that.
And staying with Buddhism for a moment,
the CEO of LinkedIn,
here in Silicon Valley, Jeff Weiner, has
written and
spoken about the importance of Buddhism in
his management.
Compassionate management, he thinks, is
the, the most important way to think
about doing business and he's been very
affected by the Dalai Lama over the years.
And so he tries to think of LinkedIn as a,
as a company that's run on Buddhist
principles but not in a way that would be
proselytizing or
demanding that people become Buddhists,
but ultimately, he would like to ha,
spread that notion of compassionate
management worldwide.
[MUSIC]